we know it's great to welcome President
Biden to the UK for I think the fourth
time since he's become president but
particularly to a part of the UK that is
very special and dear to him it also
reminds us of the contribution that
America made to the peace process as we
celebrate the 25th anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement and President
Biden and I spoke a lot about that and
we spoke in particular about the
incredible economic opportunities that
are there in store for Northern Ireland
and we've talked about the investment
potential that is there the companies
that want to invest in Northern Ireland
I think that's incredibly exciting or
been growth jobs and prosperity to
Northern Ireland and I know he shares my
ambition to see the institutions here
back up and running that's what people
in businesses in Northern Ireland
deserve
um now you're the British prime minister
why aren't we seeing more of you and him
standing together speaking together not
even going to his speech has this trip
really been worth it for you well it's
the fourth time that President Biden has
visited the UK since he's become
president and you know he and I had a
very good discussion today about a
ranger of issues economic investment in
Northern Ireland but also a range of
foreign policy issues the importance of
Economic Security and that comes on the
back of the meeting I had with him last
month in the U.S I'm seeing him again
next month of the G7 and then I'm going
to Washington in June that we're very
close partners and allies we cooperate
and talk on a range of things whether
that's supporting Ukraine or as I said
Economic Security I think actually the
relationship is in in great shape and
the president and I have lots that we're
working on together now Junior doctors
are on strike for many days there are
reports that ministers might be willing
to get around the table if the junior
doctors drop their demand from a 35 pay
rise to something more like a 17 to 19
uh pay rise is that what it would take
to to get people around the table to get
your side round the table again or is it
even lower and do you think it helps
that the gene adopter Chief is on
holiday
I was surprised to read that but look
what I'm focused on is making sure we
get the right outcome for patients and
taxpayers and I think the government's
got a track record in showing that it
can get around the table and find
reasonable compromise and a way through
these difficult situations as we've
already done with several other health
unions that represent over a million NHS
workers including nurses and paramedics
that's what we've already done and we've
done that in other sectors too so I
think I said we we are Keen to find
accommodation we we're happy to talk
about pay settlements that are
reasonable that are fair that are
affordable for the taxpayer and allow us
to continue delivering on our promise to
halve inflation because ultimately
that's what we all need to do to ease
the burdens on the cost of living that's
what the government is committed to
delivering now the Scottish first
Minister the new Scottish first Minister
has about to announce that he's going to
legally challenge The veto against uh of
uh Scotland's gender reforms what do you
make of that well we said at the time
the Secretary of State said at the time
you know it was a decision that we made
after taking very careful and considered
advice and we had concerns as the UK
government Secretary of State set this
out at the time concerns about how
Scotland's gender recognition act would
interact with reserve powers about the
operation of the equalities act the
protection of women elsewhere in the UK
as well and that's why we took the
decision to block the the grr and
obviously there's a if there's a court
process we will follow that through
um now over the weekend labor have been
claiming on social media that you don't
think adults convicted of sexually
assaulting children should go to prison
what do you say to that
I said at the beginning of this year I
was focused on delivering for the
British people there were five things I
said I wanted to do which was the half
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and stop the boat and
that's what I'm focused on day in day
out delivering for people and I think
that's what the British people want to
see from their politicians let's talk
more action making a difference on the
things that matter those are the five
priorities I set out and that's what I'm
going to focus on doing